an historic settlement means victims of
a gunman who killed nine people at a
black church in charleston south
carolina will receive tens of millions
of dollars the justice department
announced the settlement yesterday and
acknowledged that the killer was able to
buy his gun because the government
mishandled a required background check
jeff begaze is with us from washington
jeff good morning good morning the
settlement amount 88 million dollars was
chosen for a reason the shooter dylan
roof who was sentenced to die for a
federal hate crime was known to wear the
number 88 which is code for white
supremacy family members of those who
were killed say while this is a step
toward closure
no amount of money will ever bring back
their loved ones
what we do here today as lawyers and
these families is we say we stand on
justice the justice department thursday
announcing a landmark settlement for the
victims of the shooting in mother
emanuel amy church in 2015 that killed
nine during a bible study i still relive
and i still think about what happened
jennifer pickney survived the shooting
that killed her husband reverend
clemente pickney he left behind two
daughters no amount of compensation will
ever replace my father's life but it
allows me and my sister to have the
opportunity to make sure that we're
doing everything we can to make sure
that my father's legacy doesn't go away
doj agreement settled a series of
lawsuits brought after the fbi
acknowledged that its gun background
check system failed to block dylan roof
from purchasing his murder weapon a
glitch in the fbi database and human
error
allowed the killer to purchase the gun
before the background check was
completed i think it was a historical
ending to such a long
enduring process ko singleton's mother
myra died in the shooting i have a young
daughter
that has a fear of sitting in a church
because she thinks somebody of a
different color is going to come in
there and open fire even with the
settlement this is a good this is a
nightmare that will never end i have to
live with this for the rest of my life
in the years since the shooting
singleton has written a book that he
called never forgave the killer he says
he wrote it to help him through his own
grieving process in the meantime the
justice department announced thursday
that it will award more than 21 million
dollars to state and local agencies to
help investigate and prosecute hate
crimes as well as assist the victims
jamie
scared to go to church that should never
happen jeff thank you